a water crisis on the country's most
famous river threatens a crucial
shipping Corridor and could drive prices
even higher for consumers water and
parts of the Mississippi River is
sinking to record low levels because of
a month-long drought in the midwest
that's causing bottlenecks for barges
that move vital Cargoes like
agricultural products senior National
correspondent Ben Tracy shows us what's
being done to keep the river flowing
this used to be an island in the middle
of the Mississippi River reachable only
by boat now you can walk to what's known
as Tower Rock months of below normal
rainfall have sent the river to record
low levels creating chaos for barge
traffic we haven't seen these levels for
about three decades Paul Rhodey
represents the River shipping and towing
industry barges are being slowed and
stranded at the worst possible time just
as farmers are sending their Harvest
down river 60 of our AG exports travel
right down here the Mississippi River
down in New Orleans and out for export
so if we don't have barges available
that's a real problem not just for
America's Farmers but for the world
frankly it's also a critical supply
chain for everything from coal and
petroleum to fertilizer and road salt
how important is this River to moving
Goods around this country the
Mississippi River is a vital
Transportation artery it's absolutely a
water Super Highway annually will move
500 million tons give or take if you
wanted to put that on trucks you could
circle the Earth 13 times with trucks
Bumper to Bumper billions of dollars in
economic losses and higher prices for
consumers are expected as the drought
drags on what's your biggest concern
no clouds No Rain and you need more than
a little rain a lot more new delarco is
chief of operations for the Army Corps
of Engineers in St Louis this city is
now the gateway to Growing problems down
river
the Army Corps has been dredging
non-stop for three months desperately
trying to keep a nine foot deep shipping
channel open
by sucking up enough silt and sand to
fill an Olympic-sized swimming pool
every hour if this drought continues can
you dredge your way out of this we could
dredge it to a certain point and then
Mother Nature wins
Louisiana salt water from the Gulf of
Mexico is creeping up the river
threatening the drinking water supply
Baton Rouge has a new tourist attraction
a sunken ferry boat from the early 1900s
resurfaced as the water receded
this punishing drought comes as climate
change is making rainfall patterns all
over the country more extreme it is
drought or flood Washington University
Professor Robert crisp has studied the
Mississippi's flow for decades it was
your sense that this is not going to be
as reliable as we thought it once was it
clearly is not reliable when the water
is too high they can't run the barges
when the water is too low they can't run
the barges and yet the barges have to
keep running on a not so mighty
Mississippi unfortunately there's no
Silver Bullet this is irreplaceable
we've got to keep Commerce moving for
CBS more I'm Ben Tracy in St Louis